this episode is made possible by
curiosity stream
get free access to nebula the streaming
platform built by all your favorite
youtubers when you sign up for curiosity
stream at the link below
[Music]
in the united states we like to pride
ourselves on being the best at things
we spend more money than any other
nation on our military healthcare and
education
unfortunately simply throwing money at
things doesn't make you the best at them
our military despite having the budget
of the next 10 biggest spenders combined
is tremendously wasteful and is
constantly used as a destabilizing force
in regions we wish to dominate or
exploit
our health care system despite occupying
the world's number one spot for per
capita expenditure
is routinely ranked the worst in the
developed world in terms of access
efficiency and effectiveness while each
of these topics deserves its own video
in this episode we're going to focus on
the u.s education system
why it's failing our students and
teachers and what we can do to fix it
think back to your time in school what
do you remember early mornings
long windowless hallways punctuated by
locked doors a strictly regimented
schedule
your school life was dictated by the
authority of the teacher
who conditioned you with countless
commands every day sit down
open your textbook to page 10 stop
talking line up
you were punished for speaking to
classmates making a joke or coming in a
single minute late
you had to get permission to use the
restroom class started with a bell and
ended with a bell
there's another kind of institution that
follows a similar structure
it shouldn't come as a surprise that in
the u.s many of the same architects who
designed our prisons also designed our
schools
for many of us school is an unpleasant
memory sure
most of us had fun with friends we made
in class but that fun was exclusively
outside of school hours
odds are the memory of your education
itself is pretty negative
besides the experience of attending
american school the outcomes the system
produces are also less than stellar
despite our cultural obsession with
getting american students to perform
well in standardized testing
our scores fall squarely in the middle
of the pack compared to other
industrialized nations
this single-mindedness also has a more
critical consequence
by demanding our teachers simply prepare
students for testing rather than
fostering an actually effective learning
environment
we end up with students who not only
forget everything they crammed into
their heads immediately after taking the
test
but who also lack the skills required to
learn effectively
the students aren't the only ones
suffering the us has exceptionally high
teacher turnover
due to low pay and long hours and
compounding the problem
a teacher shortage so to sum up the
problem our students are unhappy
perform poorly and don't gain the
critical skills they need and our
teachers are unhappy
overworked and we don't have enough of
them to meet a growing need
a country depends on its young people
those who will grow up and take the
reins from the previous generations
so why are we failing them so badly
before we get into some potential
solutions
we need to understand the three main
problems plaguing the american education
system
these three problems are the system's
outdatedness its underfunding and its
privatization
the lack of funding and the rapid
privatization of the education system go
hand in hand
so let's start there when you think of
the average school whether elementary
middle or high school
you're generally thinking about a public
institution that is a school that is
federally funded and tasked with
providing education to all people of the
appropriate age in a given school
district free of charge
public schools have existed in the u.s
since before it officially became a
country
but the first board of education was
established in massachusetts in the year
1837
the person spearheading the education
initiative horus mann
believed that public education was the
best way to overcome poverty bridge
social gaps
and prepare young people to enter the
workforce the federal department of
education was established 30 years later
with the goal of standardizing and
helping to implement education across
the country
what may be surprising to some is that
private schools actually predate public
schools in the u.s as early as the 1660s
individual teachers were offering their
services to young people and adults as a
way to supplement their income
this private schooling often took place
in the evenings and was less structured
than typical day school
by the beginning of the american
revolution private schools had become
pretty well established and were favored
by those who could afford their fees
fast forward to more modern times and
like with health care and infrastructure
we begin to see a problem with
accelerating privatization
the practice of privatization is simple
it entails the handing off of once
public responsibilities to privately
owned companies
since the 80s there's been a consensus a
deeply flawed one but a consensus
nonetheless
that there's nothing the government can
do that the private sector can't do
better
the word better is doing some heavy
lifting here private companies often get
things done more quickly or with a
greater profit
but what free market enthusiasts fail to
realize is that the outcomes are
incredibly damaging
as is the case with american health care
or extremely fragile
as evidenced by private infrastructure
projects take the texas power grid for
example
it's entirely deregulated this allows
them to cut costs and make a greater
profit
it also sets them up for disaster as we
saw with the recent winter storm that
completely knocked out the state's power
and left millions stranded in freezing
conditions
of course a crisis like this is
considered an acceptable risk when
there's a nice profit to be had
this free market logic has slowly seeped
into the realm of education
over the past couple of decades various
federal initiatives have provided
parents the option of using federal
funds to send their children to private
schools
whether by providing so-called school
choice vouchers or allowing for the
possibility of school transfers
where students can move from low
performing schools to higher performing
private schools
this has led to a number of problems the
most obvious is that by spending federal
money to incentivize parents to enroll
their children in private school
they've robbed public schools of badly
needed funding why spend money to move
kids around when you could simply fund
the schools that are designed to be
funded by that money
because of this practice public schools
face a vicious cycle
there's not enough money to pay teachers
so teachers leave which leads to more
students in each class
which overwhelms the remaining teachers
there's not enough money for school
supplies or even basic school
maintenance
which leads to unsafe learning
environments these problems compound
over time
which makes the schools perform worse
which then suggests to the federal
government that they're doing the right
thing by incentivizing the move to
private schools
okay but if the private schools perform
better and the average parent can afford
them why not just abandon public schools
there are a few reasons
some innate to how private schools
operate and some based on the
responsibility of the federal government
first and foremost it has been long
established that the state has a
responsibility to provide access to free
education to every student
this is non-negotiable at least for now
if
public schools didn't exist there would
be students who could not afford to go
to private school
since education is a right this is
unacceptable so for the time being
the federal government cannot reasonably
get rid of public schools entirely
the other issues stem from the private
schools themselves by their very nature
private schools are not beholden to any
kind of governance when it comes to what
is taught within their walls
all they have to do is provide proof
that their education meets basic
educational standards
this has led to an upsurge in what can
be considered reactionary or
as the schools prefer traditional
education what this means in essence is
that most private schools skew intensely
religious conservative and insular
their student body is overwhelmingly
white christian and wealthy
now there's nothing inherently wrong
with a parent wanting their child to get
a religious education
but the problem is in the u.s
christianity has been co-opted by
conservatism
gone are the days when people understood
jesus to be a brown communist from the
middle east who railed against the rich
and preached inclusion decency and the
value of living humbly
most american christians have grafted
the language of conservatism onto their
faith
homophobia racism unfettered free market
economics
and a rabid hatred for anything that
could be considered even remotely
socialist
this is not by accident the political
right has adopted religious patriotic
language in an attempt to secure a large
and dedicated voting bloc
evangelicals and it's worked in modern
private schools and i should know i
attended one
it's not uncommon to see prageru videos
shown in class
it's not uncommon to see economics
classes that espouse the suicidal
free-market ideology of friedman and
rand
history classes portray the u.s as the
good guy in every conflict
including those where we were clearly in
the wrong today's supposedly christian
education would not be recognized as
such by the jesus of the bible
instead it's a new religion the religion
of free-market conservatism
it shouldn't come as a surprise that
those in power are doing their best to
get more students enrolled in private
school
indoctrinating them into the cult of
capitalism while they're young is the
only way they can produce more
pro-corporate voters
heck judging by what we've seen recently
it wouldn't come as a surprise to see
public schools go the same way
the previous administration even
suggested the creation of a commission
for patriotic education
a slate of pro-america capitalist
imperialist propaganda
this disturbing trend towards
privatization and capitalist
indoctrination aside
what's perhaps the bigger problem with
american education is the fact that the
entire system is simply outdated
remember the massachusetts school board
the one established in 1837
well that's when the standards for
education were established the stated
goal was to educate young people
but if you take a look at how school was
and is structured it becomes more clear
what education was actually for
like it is today the school day was
strictly regimented
teachers expected absolute obedience the
bell instructed students when the day
began and ended
and punishment was doled out for any
perceived non-compliance
if the students retained some basic
arithmetic great but the real goal was
to produce obedient
servile workers for the factories of the
industrial revolution
step onto a factory floor and what's
expected obedience
focus the ability to follow instructions
for hours on
end the day even began and ended with a
bell school was then
and remains today an instrument to
instill discipline to mass-produce
agreeable little cogs for the industrial
machine
the standardization of schooling ensured
these cogs were nice and uniform
easily replaceable and expendable today
nearly two centuries later
factory labor is no longer the prime
driver of the economy companies still
need workers but they demand
a new set of skills young people
entering the workforce are expected to
be able to be flexible
creative and on-call at unreasonable
hours even from a capitalist perspective
modern day schooling does not adequately
prepare our students for the real world
of course preparing students for a
lifetime of servitude should not be the
goal of a good education
let's examine the main issues in regards
to outdatedness
which of these two hypothetical classes
sounds more applicable to real life
latin or home economics guess which one
is more commonly taught
if the goal of school is to prepare kids
for the real world as we're meant to
believe
we are doing our students a great
disservice why don't we teach home
economics classes
why don't we teach high schoolers how to
file taxes what about useful things like
basic first aid
we simply don't teach applicable skills
then there's the fact that school
curriculum just hasn't kept pace with
advancements in modern technology
basic computer classes are offered as
electives if at all
even less common are video production
digital art coding
web design 3d modeling and countless
other modern skills
we're letting students down when we
don't acquaint them with modern tools
as a personal anecdote i have a younger
sister who's shown a proclivity for
drawing
her school's art class while led by a
good teacher doesn't even mention new
digital techniques
since i work creatively for a living i
took the liberty of teaching her a bit
about digital art and apps like
procreate
her skills have improved more in the
last two months than in the previous two
years and i'm no artist
i just told her about the app and
suggested she watched some youtube
videos
imagine if public schools had the
funding for even a handful of art
tablets or ipads
kids could come out of middle school
with skills they could translate into a
rewarding career or hobby by the time
they graduated from high school or
college
okay so what are some solutions we could
pursue it's all well and good to say
teach better classes but that only
addresses part of the problem
the root cause of many of the issues our
education system faces
is that we simply don't have an
incentive to teach our students
as with anything in america if there's
no financial incentive
nothing will change the profit motive is
the bottom line
private schools have an incentive to at
least prepare students for standardized
testing
so that their parents will be happy and
keep paying tens of thousands of dollars
per year for tuition
but that education comes packaged with
truly damaging ideology
so making private schools more
accessible would not be a long-term
solution
as those students would go on to pass
even more ludicrous free market
education reforms
vocational schools are an option if we
truly believe the only purpose of
education should be to prepare students
for the job market
there's a lot to be said for picking a
trade and excelling in it electricians
welders
ac technicians these are all critical
roles in our society
one problem with vocational schools is
that they typically come with a tuition
which can be a difficult burden for many
families homeschooling is another option
though in the u.s it often carries a
similar connotation to private schools
many homeschooled children come from
very religious backgrounds and are kept
separate from other kids their age
which can lead to serious developmental
issues that being said
there are plenty of homeschooling
programs that include on-location
learning such as in museums or on
community college campuses
this offers a more diverse hands-on
experience for students and can provide
an excellent learning environment
depending on the child
now that right there is something we
don't discuss enough in the us
appropriate education depends on the
child we don't all learn the same way
some students learn more quickly than
others some require hands-on experience
some learn simply by watching or
listening by creating one
single standardized educational template
we're trying to standardize a whole
spectrum of humanity
and that just doesn't work there are
some types of education
such as those found in montessori
schools that try to foster a more
diverse learning environment
allowing students to learn at different
paces and having students who grasp
subjects more quickly work with those
who are struggling
this allows more room for personal
growth but also fosters empathy and
interpersonal skills
the jury is still out on whether
montessori schools are strictly better
than more traditional education
but some studies seem to say pretty
conclusively that their students fare
better than those in standard schools
overall the moral of the story is that
like always privatization is harming the
majority in the pursuit of ever greater
profits
the defunding of public schools has
caused our country to slip further and
further behind our peer nations
our inability to keep up with the times
has produced students who are woefully
underequipped to compete with students
from other countries
even from a capitalist perspective it
should be clear that our education
system isn't working
and maybe that's the point maybe for the
ruling class it's desirable for the
average american student to fail so that
they're forced to take the lower paying
jobs that generate huge profits for
their executives
whether that's the case or not i think
it's safe to say that we cannot expect
the federal government to solve the
problem
for at least the past 40 years they've
been completely controlled by massive
corporations
and will continue to trend towards
suicidal free market non-solutions
instead i would suggest that education
on the community level could be a
worthwhile endeavor
if we expanded the idea of homeschooling
to include other members of your
community
we could create localized educational
templates that not only allowed for more
individualized expression
but also catered towards the needs and
unique perspectives of each community
local experts could teach small classes
in their respective fields
students could learn the history of
their town city or region parents could
build a network of trust where they
could all help supervise or teach each
other's children
which in turn would strengthen the
community fostering cooperation
friendship and empathy these communities
could engage in sort of small-scale
exchange programs
day or week-long trips where students
could experience the realities of
different communities
which would provide them with worldly
experience and a refreshing change of
pace
we tend to get stuck in the notion that
what we have now is the only possibility
whether that's in regards to healthcare
entire economic systems or education
there are so many improvements we could
make so many possibilities worth
exploring
and few are more important than how we
teach the next generation
more and more often young people are
turning to alternative sources for their
education
youtube is a great one i've learned a
lot just from watching videos on topics
i'm interested in
another great place to learn about all
sorts of interesting topics is curiosity
stream
if you liked today's video i highly
recommend you check out education in the
age of technology on curiosity stream
it's a fascinating look at the potential
changes to education in the 21st century
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula so we
don't have to worry about demonetization
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free that's less than 15 bucks a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since most of us are still
waiting for the vaccine
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiositystream or
check out nebula's exclusive content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below you're helping us produce more
content without the fear of
demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you